no I think you know I could never
it's in mark or John in the Bible where
Pontius Pilate is supposedly seeking the
truth about Christ and you know and he
says what is truth you know is it the
truth you know is the truth about this
man or is the truth about what will
happen if I make the wrong decision for
example I mean I'm quoting it very very
badly here but so I think that there
probably is not absolute truth but that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't seek to
find facts it doesn't mean that we
should lie I think the reason lying
becomes so serious is because to make a
society to do things to make buildings
stand to do a heart transplant to do
anything that is important we have to
know that the people around us are
telling us things that are real if not
true we have to be able to rely on the
things that that we are told as fact
because we want to believe that someone
went and tried something first and
therefore learn to that and they come
and say well I've been outside and it's
raining today right till we be learning
to trust that make decisions upon that
fact so I don't know if I'm really a
seeker of truth in terms of like is
someone telling the truth I think I'm
really a student of I'm a student of
human beings yeah I think that's a
better way of putting it then that I'm a
seeker of truth I'm a student of human
beings and their motivations
and what causes them to do what they say
they're going to do or what gets in the
way of that
I think it's very hard in fact not to
see reality through the lens of your own
experience and I also think it's
difficult to put past experiences behind
us past experiences that become that
lens it's very hard to change that lens
and we don't have a version of surgery
to help us do that I suppose we used to
think that things like psychotherapy
could help with it but now most people
though a psychopharmacologist and
they're less interested in the process
of telling their myths to someone who
should understand them and tearing those
myths apart when they don't help you
know one of my favorite artists is and
was Jacob Lawrence and I interviewed him
when he was quite old and he was talking
to me about growing up uptown in Harlem
and I was very interested in how
somebody who grew up uptown in Harlem
would have been able to mingle as well
as he did he was embraced by the
downtown art crowd that is to say the
white you know mainstream art crowd
embraced him
his work and you know he talked about
how when he was a boy if a white man
were to walk on the street in Harlem or
if he were to go downtown and see white
men walking on the street he would
automatically think to himself
that's a linter so to him every white
man was a potential injure just like you
know there were he would have been white
people who would believe that every
black man is a potential rapist or thief
well he thought every white man was a
potential winter and so I said to him I
said well how did you get over that
said well you know he said the simplest
thing but I had such residents I thought
he said you know it's just like when
you're a child and you believe that
they're ghosts and goblins under the bed
and then one day you don't and so many
of us have different kinds of ghosts and
goblins we might think that we aren't so
attractive because somebody told us that
or we might think that we're very
attractive that we should be on display
because somebody told us that or we
might think that we have to lie if we've
done something wrong so we have these
things these past experiences that begin
to almost predict for us how we're going
to behave in any given situation and I
think it's very hard to recraft them and
I'm very interested in how people either
succeed and re-crafting those things or
not